from Congress to Huffington Post sexual
harassment is everywhere the bottom
falls out for Roy Moore or does it
really and Jeff Sessions heads to the
hill I'm Ben Shapiro this is the venture
Pierrot show
this is a jam-packed show for you today
we are going to give you very latest on
Roy Moore that is heating up because it
now appears that a lot of his media
supporters are moving away from but when
war isn't going anywhere and he is not
sinking in the polls the latest poll has
Roy Moore up 49 43 there's the real
possibility the guy about whom credible
allegations of sexual molestation have
been made will end up being elected to
the United States Senate which of course
puts the Republican Party in a very
interesting position we'll discuss all
of that plus again see Jeff Sessions on
the hill should there be a special
counsel for Hillary Shep Smith he did
when went after some folks on the right
for talking about uranium one so I want
to let you know what's true and what's
false about uranium one we'll get to all
of those things but first we say thank
you to our sponsors over at helix so I'm
on the road I'm actually broadcasting
today from Fox News I was on outnumbered
earlier today as well as Fox and Friends
and I did not sleep great one of the
reasons I did not sleep great is because
I was not on my helix sleep mattress my
helix sleep mattress at home is the only
place that I can sleep comfortably they
have ruined sleep for me everywhere else
helix sleep offers something that
doesn't exist anywhere else a mattress
personalized your unique preferences and
sleeping style that will not set you
back thousands of dollars go to helix
sleep comm /ban take their simple two to
three minutes sleep quiz they'll build a
custom mattress that will be the best
thing you have ever slept on for couples
they'll even personalize each side of
the mattress it is less expensive than
if you go to a mattress store and buy a
comparable mattress it's great it rides
in your mail you unpack the box and then
it inflates right in front of you
because foam mattress you pop it on your
bed you're ready to go and you can try
it for 100 nights if you don't love it
they'll pick it up and refund you in
full go to helix sleep comm slash bed
right now that's helix sleep comm slash
bed right now you get 50 bucks off
toward your custom mattress that's helix
sleep comm slash Ben for $50 off your
order again helix sleep calm slash Ben
use that slash Ben so that they know
that we sent you an get 50 bucks off
your order okay so we begin today with a
general observation
sexual harassment is apparently
everywhere this is sort of a shocking
story that went completely under the
under the radar yesterday but there is a
democratic woman named Jackie Speier
she's a congresswoman on the hill and
she in an interview yesterday MSNBC she
said there are two members of the House
who have been hit with serious sexual
harassment
shows the house over the past several
years has paid out 15 million dollars in
sexual harassment claims that's your
taxpayer dollars in mind paying off
women for guys who can't keep their
their grubby hands off so here's what
jackie speier had to say now we we do
know that there's a about 15 million
dollars that has been paid out by the
house on behalf of harasser x' in the
last ten to fifteen years fifteen
million dollars has been paid out over
sexual harassment claims so obviously
more than one member of Congress you
know how many over time that is I know
that some of them are former members now
I don't really know okay that's a lot of
money it's a serious amount of money and
if we're all gonna go nuts over Bill
O'Reilly's alleged 32 million dollar
settlement on sexual harassment 15
million bucks is a lot of money this is
why Paul Ryan the Speaker of the House
has now come out and said that we need
to have mandatory harassment training in
Congress first of all I'm shocked that
they didn't have mandatory harassment
training before like pretty much every
major company that I've worked yet has
had to have some sort of form of HR
training including me of watch a sexual
harassment tape one of these dumb tapes
from the 80s where they show you that
you're not allowed to grab a woman's
butt which you should have known since
you're not a jerk but in any case Paul
Ryan comes out he says we need mandatory
harassment training it is today's
hearing was another important step in
our efforts to combat sexual harassment
and ensure a safe workplace I want to
especially thank my colleagues who
shared their stories going forward the
house will adopt a policy of mandatory
anti harassment and anti discrimination
training for all members and staff our
goal is not only to raise awareness but
also make abundantly clear that
harassment in any form has no place in
this institution so I'm not a general
fan of anti harassment training I don't
think that her Astor's stopped harassing
because because of this harasser stopped
harassing when they feel there are
consequences Mark Levin has suggested
that speaker Ryan and the Senate and
senator Mitch McConnell should step down
from their positions if they've been
covering up sexual harassment I think
that's a little bit much I but what I do
think that they should be coming forward
with names and naming and shaming sexual
harassers if the allegations are
credible seems to me the best way of
going about alleviating this particular
problem rather than paying out my money
and yours from our wallets so that some
sexually predatorial congressperson can
get his rock
it's not just in Congress this is one of
the worst kept secrets in Congress by
the way is is the the amount of drunken
luxury that happens in Congress is
really quite astonishing it's been true
for pretty much centuries at this point
also the the fallout in Hollywood
continues a more sexual harassment in
Hollywood so John Stewart comes out he
says I was just stunned stunned to learn
about the revelations about louis c.k
here's the estimable Jon Leibowitz
stunned I think you know you give your
friends a benefit of the doubt I tried
to think of it in terms of you know I've
had friends who have compulsions and who
have done things gambling or drinking or
drugs and we've lost some of them some
of them have died and you always find
yourself back to a moment of did I miss
something could I have done more are the
thing and in this situation I think we
all could have we all could have is a
way of saying I couldn't have you could
have the answer is yes Jon Stewart you
probably could have considered that
you're asked the specific question in
2016 and tried away from answering it
meanwhile there are certain harassers in
Hollywood who are continuing to get away
with it George Takei as you recall he
made a statement on Howard Stern's show
in which he openly admitted to grabbing
men by their penises men who were
skittish to encourage them in their in
their proclivities and here was here was
his original audio I want to play that
then I want to show you what he said in
his statement and people are letting him
off the hook for this did you ever grab
anyone by the against their will you
never sexually harassed an a boner have
you it's some people that are kind of
skittish right or may be afraid and
you're trying to persuade that but you
know do we need to call the police the
answer is yes you need to call the
police here was George Takei's statement
that came out on Monday quote many have
raised concern over a back and forth
between Howard Stern and myself where we
joked about me touching men during my
Star Trek days 50 years ago well first
of all it didn't sound like that was
your Star Trek
it sounds like it's a pretty consistent
question out of context I agree that the
joke was distasteful I'm very sorry he
and I made fun out of a serious matter
for decades I have played the part of a
nadie grandpa when I visit Howard's show
a caricature I now regret but I want to
be clear I've never forced myself upon
someone during a date sometimes my dates
were the initiators sometimes I was it
was always by mutual consent I see now
that it has come across poorly in the
awkward sketch that is not a sketch okay
you heard the audio yourself but George
Takei will get away with it
he he like he like Kevin Spacey is
choosing to live as a gay man I guess
and so will get away with it meanwhile
there's a story from The Huffington Post
that sexual harassment was tolerated on
a routine basis over at Huffington Post
this is from Gizmodo what they say is
Arianna Huffington's history with a
former managing editor who's transferred
to launch HuffPost India was later
revealed to be the result of an HR
investigation into whether he had
sexually harassed multiple young women
in the New York office shows that
Huffington wasn't overly concerned with
sexual harassment in the office his moto
recently revisited those allegations and
not only independently confirmed that
the investigation was indeed the reason
for that Managing Editors transfer but
that huffington knew about his actions
before they were reported to HR
according to a former employee Aaron
Krantz the woman who wrote this piece
called Melanie Aaron Krantz she says by
turning a blind eye she bore ultimate
responsibility for any issues that arose
under her leadership according to the
report Huffington sure the elevation of
the guy named Jimmy Soni who was then
managing editor of the website and it
was common knowledge around the newsroom
and and huffington knew about it that he
was sexually harassing the help vice
there's a there's a story about Vice
today being hit with serious allegations
of sexual harassment so this is to say
sexual harassment apparently is out of
control and the question is why are we
just noticing this announced there are
two theories as to why we are just
noticing this now theory number one is
the david frum theory this is the
optimistic theory of human nature which
is everyone's been sexually harassing
for decades and only now do we care
because we're better than they were a
decade ago right we didn't care about
Bill Clinton a decade ago we care about
Bill Clinton at speak us we're better
now and then there's Theory number two
theory number two is that bad men have
always sexually harassed women but the
people only care about it now
particularly on the left because they're
trying to get Donald Trump and Roy Moore
I think that this is the correct theory
I don't think the left really cares very
much about sexual harassment I think the
left has been
bring up their their lack of care about
sexual harassment for years they use a
changing sexual standard to basically
allow them to let people off the hook
they want to let off the hook and to put
on the hook people they want to put on
the hook so right now they want to put
the Roy Moore and Donald Trump on the
hook and therefore they're gonna pretend
to take sexually harassed sexual
harassment super seriously when it's
Anthony Weiner or Bill Clinton then it's
a completely different story
the reason that I say this is because
there's a piece in voxcom from an
execrable columnist named Matt Iglesias
he wrote about a two thousand word essay
about why Bill Clinton should have
resigned from office in 1998 now I
checked my calendar this morning it
turns out it's not 1998 it's 2017 so
he's 19 years late to the party
Glacia admits that at the time he wanted
Clinton to stay he said he was glad to
see Clinton prevail and regarded the
whole sordid manner as primarily the
fault of congressional Republicans
excessive scandal mongering but he
admits I think we got it wrong
what we should have talked about was men
abusing their social and economic power
over younger and less powerful limits it
doesn't talk about one Nina Broderick he
hasn't talked about Kathleen Willey he
talks specifically about Monica Lewinsky
and here's what he says quote excuse me
it was far from the most egregious case
of workplace sexual misconduct in
American history but it was unusually
high-profile the facts were not in
dispute the perpetrator had a lot of
nominal feminist ideological commitments
and political leaders who shared those
commitments had the power to force him
from office had he resigned in shame we
all might have made a collective
cultural and political decision that a
person called leveraging power over
women in inappropriate ways ought to be
fired instead we lost nearly two decades
yes yes we did so where are you on Bob
Menendez Matt well it turns out that he
doesn't want bob menendez to step down
and if you had this choice now he really
wouldn't want Clinton to step down
anyway he says the reason that Clinton
should have stepped down is because he
abused power relationships this is my
favorite part of his little article he
says Republicans shouldn't have bothered
going after Bill Clinton for perjury
instead they should have used the
feminist line the Monica Lewinsky was
cudgelled into her affair they should
have said that Clinton seduction of
Lewinsky was quote morally bankrupt in
contributing in a meaningful way to
serious social problem that
disadvantages millions of women
throughout their lives that wouldn't
have worked of course I was there in
1998 I recall that at the time the left
was suggesting the Monica Lewinsky was a
who was
positioning bill not a victimize
innocent pressured by the most powerful
man on earth if the right had suggested
that she was an innocent proposition by
the most powerful man on earth and this
was sexual harassment the left would
then accuse the right of depriving
Monica Lewinsky of her agency and being
sexist there's a beautiful thing about
being part of the left you can always
find an excuse to attack the people you
want to attack and the proof is in the
pudding because Iglesias says the real
reason that Clinton should have been
dumped in 1998 is cuz the Al Gore was
vice president and nothing would have
changed he says and he says now it's
worthwhile dumping bill over but it
wouldn't been worthwhile last year he
says now that Hillary is out of
electoral politics and has emerged as a
bigger draw and more important political
force than her husband there's no excuse
for Democrats not to look back on these
events with more objectivity you wonder
what you wonder why so many Republicans
are backing Roy Moore it's because
they're using precisely the the mirror
negative of this the the Polaroid
negative of this particular argument
right Matt Iglesias is basically saying
the Bob Menendez shouldn't step down
because the current governor is Chris
Christie if he waits a few months and he
steps down then the governor will be
will be a Democrat and then everything
will be great he says that Bill Clinton
should have stepped down because Al Gore
was the vice president so in other words
he doesn't really care about sexual
harassment or at least he cares about
sexual harassment up to the point it
means political sacrifice then he shied
away and then he wonders why people in
Alabama are backing Roy Moore why there
are so many Republicans who are willing
to back Roy Moore even thinking that
these allegations are correct or at
least or at least credible so I want to
talk a little bit more about this but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriots apply so if
you're trying to get prepared for an
emergency and you're looking around your
house and figuring okay there could be a
natural disaster or god forbid a
terrorist attack you know a crime wave
whatever it is that requires you to stay
inside for a period of a couple of days
without going to the grocery store well
that's what my Patriot supply is for
okay there's a reason that FEMA
recommends three days of emergency
supplies and you may need more than that
and that's why you should get your 102
servings survival food kit for only $99
it includes breakfast lunches and
dinners it is shipped to your home for
free again it's 102 servings that means
that if you have a four members of your
family then you're going to be getting
you know twenty five meals per person
basically it's one hundred and two
servings order a kit for yourself right
now call eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen go online to
prepare with Ben
the emergency flute lasts up to 25 years
in storage my Patriot supply the people
that you can trust folks around the
office who have tasted their food they
say it tastes like home cooking and
again you buy it once stick it in the
closet forget about it and then one day
you need it you were prepared the guy
next door wasn't that's why you need to
go to 888 803 1413 give them a call or
prepare with been calm again eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen or
prepare with been calm okay so with this
as background the fact that sexual
harassment is is now obviously
commonplace all over the place and the
fact that media are paying attention for
political motivations we have to ask
ourself a question okay we as
conservatives have to ask ourself a
question should it matter should it
matter now we've been asking this
question for last several days I've
suggested that it absolutely should
matter whether Roy Moore was molesting
fourteen or sixteen year olds or whether
that are crowded credible allegations
that he is doing so but there are a lot
of people who are saying listen the left
is politically motivated if this were
leftist they wouldn't be doing the same
thing The Washington Post might not have
even reported this story if it were
about doug jones as opposed to Roy Moore
so why should we deprive ourselves of a
Senate seat in order to show the world
what gentlemen we are which is a fine
and solid question there they're
basically three ways that this can go
from here okay and two of those ways
don't involve depriving yourself of the
Senate seat way number one is is the
worst that is more stays on the ballot
and splits votes and doug jones ends up
in the senate that is that is
politically speaking for the republicans
the worst because then they have 51
votes in the senate it's very difficult
for them to pass legislation with 52 let
alone 51 it means that Lisa Murkowski
and John McCain or Susan Collins and
John McCain two senators can basically
stymie the rest of the Republican agenda
for the next couple of years at the very
least that's a possibility and so people
are shying away from that possibility so
that leaves two other possibilities one
is a write-in campaign the problem with
the write-in campaign is that Moore says
he's not going he's now Jennifer
Holliday in in in Dreamgirls right he's
telling you he's not going he's just not
going to he's gonna cling on there with
his fingernails he will not leave he's
repeating this and he's looking at the
polls and saying why should I leave I'm
raising more money than I ever had he
brings like 250,000 dollars yesterday
which is sort of a sad commentary on the
nature of our reactionary politics the
Roy Moore is Ray
way more money in the aftermath of child
sex allegations than he was before that
but people hate the media just that much
and they think it's a political hit just
that much so he stays in they split the
vote Doug Jones wins possibility number
two is that there is a right in Canada
to see for Jeff Sessions Jeff Sessions
would be the best pick you won 96
percent of the vote in the last Alabama
Senate race you put Luther strange in
the right in it's not gonna help both
there's strange in the right in and
that's going to be that's gonna be a
serious problem because Luther strange
couldn't even win a primary against Roy
Moore there been people suggesting that
Richard burr who's the current senator
of Alabama should step down and then run
for the open seat as a write-in
candidate and then his seat will come up
with for a special election that's a
possibility too in other words using
some sort of nationai ssin to prevent
more from being elected that would be
the best but the most plausible solution
and then the most plausible outcome here
is that more actually gets elected the
more stays in more wins the election and
then Republicans in Congress have a have
to decide they have to make a decision
are they gonna see him or are they not
the case for seating him is the people
of Alabama have spoken they heard the
allegations they didn't trust them not
our problem the case for not seating him
is credible allegations of child
molestation I am in the camp that says
that if he's elected you should not seat
him the reason I say this is because
like the founders I am NOT a Democrat I
am a Republican that means with small D
and small R I'm not somebody who
believes that the will of the people in
its purest form must always be done I
think that the exercise of independent
judgement by legislators is important
which is why I think character is
important in legislators I'm a believer
that the electoral college was created
specifically to prevent dictatorship
right I'm a believer that that the
institutions of our government were
created with the knowledge that there
should be people who every once in a
while have to do the right thing even in
spite of their constituents this to me
seems like pretty clear-cut case of that
especially because in the amount of
Glacia smash the governor of Alabama is
a Republican who will then appoint a
Republican to fill the seats at least
until the next a special election so
it's interesting to see where everybody
is coming down on all of this and it's
also interesting to see just how how
much dirty tricks are being used in
Alabama I'm not just talking about you
know quote-unquote dirty tricks against
Roy Moore you know a credible allegation
is a credible
but by people who are associated
presumably with more so we don't know
who sent this fake robo call but there
was a fake robo call that was going
around Alabama and this fake robo call
was from a guy who characterizes himself
as Lenny Lenny Bernstein from the
Washington Post
offering money to people to make false
allegations against Roy Moore the
suspicion is of course that this is
someone who's associated with the Roy
Moore campaign and that this is somebody
who's attempting to convince people that
all of the allegations are false oh that
the Washington Post pay people off
here's what it sounded like I love they
use a Jewish name for it really a nice
dog whistle there here here is the the
audio for the Washington Post
anyone at this address is a female
between the ages of 54 to 57 years old
we're gonna make damage using remarks
about Canada anymore
for a war that between 5,000 or 7,000
dollars there will not be fully
investigating these claims however will
an ingress report I can be reached by
email al burns Elberton seen in
washington post car the purpose of this
of course is not to actually gather
information l Bernstein a Washington
Post com apparently doesn't exist the
purpose is to issue robot calls to make
people think that this was what the
Washington Post was doing really really
gross stuff very very unpleasant stuff
so that's happening so as all of this
happens even the conservatives in media
have broken down into two groups sean
hannity who's obviously signaling from
the white house last night on his
program
Nashawn talks regularly with President
Trump they're very close apparently they
speak nearly every night and and Sean
basically laid the wood to more he said
listen you have 24 hours to figure out a
good way to rebut these allegations or
you should get out of the race between
this interview that I did and the
inconsistent answers between him saying
I never knew this girl and then that
yearbook comes out for me the judge has
24 hours you must immediately and fully
come up with the satisfactory
explanations for your inconsistencies
that I just showed you must remove any
doubt if you can't do this then judge
Moore needs to get out of this race okay
so that was seen as an ultimatum from
the White House Trump of course has
remained utterly immovable and in
silence on this issue which is amazing
it's amazing because
Trump is the person who could help solve
all of this if Trump jumped in with both
feet ins and more needs to get out and
then all of a sudden the polls show that
Moore's base was completely eroding then
you might actually get a write-in
candidate see that would be worthwhile
because writing can diseases are tough
but Trump staying out of this race is a
real problem
Trump has continued to maintain silence
I hope he doesn't say I think from you
know should know better than that it's
not just hannity tucker carlson who i
didn't watch a show earlier this week so
i don't know if he was inclined to to
doubt the allegations but whatever he
was doing earlier this week now Tucker
says that Moore who's been hiding behind
Christianity has been hiding behind his
faith saying I'm out you know they're
out to get me just like Jesus kind of
thing Carlson says that's nonsense Roy
Moore has every right to protest his
innocence and maybe he is innocent what
he's not allowed to do is drag God into
all of this God is not accused of
trolling for teenagers in shopping malls
this is not about Christianity it's
about Roy Moore and it just credits
Christianity when Christians allow more
to use his faith as a shield it's
offensive to real believers and this of
course is exactly correct good for
Tucker Carlson so it looks like the
bottom is falling out a little bit for
for Roy Moore except in his home state
so he does have some media defenders
Rush Limbaugh was suggesting on his show
that a search-and-destroy more a Search
and Destroy mission against Roy Moore is
really Mitch McConnell's doing it's
really about Mitch McConnell that all
these people are jumping on board
because they hate Roy Moore listen I had
not said that you should not vote for
Roy Moore I was very uncomfortable with
Roy Moore I criticized way more but I
had not openly stated I think I said
that if I were in Alabama I wouldn't
vote for him but I also said very
similar to what before any of these
allegations came out very similar to
what I said about Donald Trump which is
you know I saw I certainly understand
voting for Roy Moore to prevent a
Democrat from taking the seat but after
these allegations the idea that this is
really about McConnell anymore that's
all people have bad faith who are
seeking to take down Roy Moore it
doesn't really hold but Russia's trying
to rush was trying to push that
yesterday Annan has been very upfront
about the objective he has and that's to
get Mitch McConnell out of the Senate
and so I don't think I even even if all
we had was one allegation against judge
Moore this was gonna be it for judge
Moore
didn't matter because this is this is
now being used to send a message to what
to Bannon and his group that you just
you you think you're gonna get rid of me
well take a look at what's gonna happen
every time you try okay that's that's
not really true so been and wants to
make it about that Bannon wants to make
it about it's me versus McConnell but it
really is not about him versus McConnell
at all at this point it's just about the
truth or falsity of the allegations
Bandon by the way continues to stick by
more the reason he continues to stick by
more is because he stapled himself to
Moore's leg is more one the primaries
and then trying to claim credit he was
he was the chicken in staple day he was
the the the dog that is stapled himself
to the chickens leg to cross the road
and then claim credit for giving the
chicken a ride that's not actually what
happened in this particular case but
it's a seductive way of moving attention
off of the actual allegations and toward
the politics of the situation okay so
before I go any further and talk about
people in Alabama who are continuing to
support Roy Moore including mo Brooks oh
there was a representative from Alabama
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over the u.s. CCA so if you're
a gun owner can you say with 100%
confidence that your family and your
home are safe what if you're forced to
pull the trigger do you know what's
gonna happen when the police arrive well
if you need to know these answers and
you probably do then you need the
answers from the US CCA's complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
you're about to miss your chance to get
yours completely free unless you go over
to defend my family now calm right now
and register in that guide you'll find
out how to detect attackers before they
see you the safest most dangerous place
is sit in a restaurant how to
responsibly own and store a gun
particularly if you have small children
they're only offering this to my
listeners for a few days if you want
your free copy you need to go right now
and sign up at defend my family now calm
they'll even give you a bonus home
defense checklist that you can take a
look at defend my family now calm right
now get that free book before it's gone
it's a free audiobook as well so you
finish the show you still have a ride
home
and now you need to know you you have
something to listen to so again it's
defend my family now com from our good
friends over at the u.s. concealed-carry
Association okay so it's not just rush
who is who's basically trying to cast
this in political terms mo Brooks
thought made what I thought was maybe
most intellectually honest argument here
he basically said listen it doesn't
really matter what Roy Moore
has done or not done at least he's not
Doug Jones and he's not gonna vote for
abortion said I believe the Democrats
will do great damage to our country is
it I believe the Democrats will do
damage for a country a myriad of issues
then he's a sprinting away from the
reporter so obviously not questions that
Mel Brooks would like to would like to
answer
you know bad candidates who refuse to
get out that the Roy Moore is refusing
to get out because he believes he can
win and the polls show that he can win
and this demonstrates why the voters
need to stop thinking in binary terms in
terms of personalities binary terms and
in moral terms are good binary terms in
terms of personality are not good so
it's not a binary choice between Steve
ban and and Mitch McConnell it's not a
binary choice between Roy Moore and and
Doug Jones especially not now if you
went through support from Roy Moore you
could easily get a write-in candidate
and you could fix this problem in a much
more in a much more smooth way but
people don't want to make the binary
moral choice so instead they've swivel
to binary personality choices you know
do I do I like Doug Jones or do I like
where I'm or do I like Steve Allen's or
like Mitch McConnell there's only one
binary choice here do you think it is
important enough not to have an alleged
child molester sitting in the Senate to
not vote for him and vote for someone
else and I'm not talking about voting
for Doug Jones I'm talking about voting
for a write-in candidate or do you hate
the media so much and you suspect the
media so much and you think the whole
thing's rigged that you're willing to
take the risk that you're putting
somebody in the Senate who is an utter
piece of human debris so these are
questions that I think we all ought to
ask ourselves in all honesty well that's
not even close to the all the news that
we have to get to today we're also gonna
get to Jeff Sessions on the hill in just
a moment but for that you're gonna have
to go over and subscribe
daily wire.com $9.99 a month means that
you can get a subscription to daily
wire.com see the rest of our show on
video live see the rest of the Michael
Noel's show live on video see the rest
of the Ender Clavin show live on video
later when you download the show you can
do it without ads and also when you get
the annual subscription you can get the
very greatest in all beverage vessels it
was so precious to me that I couldn't
even bring it on the plane with me
I couldn't even I couldn't even bring it
on the plane because I didn't want to
risk losing it it's that precious to me
but the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr is very popular all across the
country
that for your $99 subscription plus you
get all the other benefits as well if
you just want to listen later go over to
YouTube please subscribe to our channel
we have all sorts of great videos that
come out over there you can also go over
to iTunes or SoundCloud and download the
show there by subscribing and leaving us
a review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile Jeff sessions was on the
hill the Attorney General was on the
hill yesterday to answer questions about
a variety of issues ranging from leaks
inside the Trump administration its
impossibility of setting up a special
counsel for Hillary Clinton now I want
to start this discussion about the
special counsel for Hillary Clinton by
discussing what exactly the special
counsel before so there are two separate
questions that have really come out in
the context of why we might need a
special counsel and it really is more
why we need an investigation not
necessarily a special counsel so those
are two separate questions too
so number one question do we need a
special counsel number two question for
what so well that's for the second
question first what is the for what why
wouldn't you need a special counsel so
why would you need an investigation so
the reason that you need investigation
into Hillary Clinton is because Hillary
Clinton hired fusion GPS a Russian
connected firm in order to dig up dirt
on Donald Trump and then it appears that
that that material was used as the basis
for a FISA requests from the FBI there
are questions is whether the FBI
actually continued to pay for this
dossier some of which has been
discredited and so the question is
really whether Hillary Clinton's did
anything illegal been using a Russian
connected source in order to promote in
order to promote a hit on Donald Trump
we don't know the answers to that I
think there's some unfilled gaps in that
suspicion I think that we'd have to
figure out that Hillary number one knew
that she was getting information
directly from the Russian government or
that you paid to the Russian government
for that information there was some
exchange that actually took place or
didn't take place some sort of favor
that was being done we'd have to find
out what the story is there that is
Story number one story number two is the
Iranian one scandal so the left has been
going crazy why are we even talking
about uranium one so one of the people
who spent some time quote-unquote
debunking the uranium one scandal
yesterday was Shep Smith Shep Smith of
course is a left-leaning host on Fox
News and he spent a significant amount
of time on his show yesterday debunking
what he thought was the foolishness of
looking at the uranium one scandal to
begin with here was his description
uranium one is the name of a South
Africa based mining company back in 2007
it merged with Eurasia energy based in
Canada and in 2010 the mining arm of the
Russian nuclear agency Raza Tom bought
controlling interest in the company
among other places that mining company
had operations in Wyoming that amounted
to what the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission's or the NRC said was at the
time about 20% of uranium production
capacity in the u.s. today the NRC says
it's about 10% now here's the accusation
nine people involved in the deal made
donations to the Clinton Foundation
totaling more than 140 million dollars
in exchange Secretary of State Clinton
approved the sale to the Russians a quid
pro quo okay and then Shepard Smith
would go on to debunk this right Shepard
Smith would say well she didn't approve
the sale to the Russians it was approved
by a bunch of agencies and it wasn't 140
million dollars and one of the people
who was accused of giving all this money
to Hillary Clinton had left rasa tahn by
the time this happened all of this is
true but it's not the whole story so I'm
gonna tell you the whole story of what
exactly happened with uranium 1 this is
not according to me this is according to
leftist sources like PolitiFact and the
New York Times so here is what we know
there's an item Frank Giustra okay Frank
Jastrow was a close confidant of the
Clintons he owned that company that he
heard Shep Smith mentioned they're
called Eurasia it was sold to uranium 1
in 2007 just recessed he divested his
personal stake in the company at that
time
but his shareholders owned 60% of the
company and there's no way to confirm
the truth of his claim in 2010 rasa tahn
tried to buy 51% of the company this
rose to the level of the government
because this looked like a security
problem not because they were gonna ship
all of the Iranian from the United
States to Russia and make nukes but
because it actually deprived the United
States of a strategic nuclear asset that
was required for our military because we
had a uranium shortage in 2013 Russia
bought the entirety of uranium 1 with
the approval of the Committee on foreign
investment in the United States CFIUS as
well as the u.s. the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission's and Utah agencies the State
Department had to sign off because the
State Department was part of the CFIUS
Hillary claims she had nothing to do
with green-lighting this she didn't stop
it from going through so the again the
acquisition that gesture I had divested
himself at this point so all of his
donations to the Clinton Foundation had
nothing to do with uranium 1 and in
reality it was just about four million
dollars that was donated to the Clinton
Foundation from people associated with
uranium 1 this is a little simplistic so
here's the full story this is courtesy
of the New York Times in a 2015 piece
they report the uranium won its
acquisition actually sort of began in
2005 when just Russ still owned the
company quote with mr. Clinton at his
side according to The Times the two men
had flown aboard mr. jester as private
jet to Almaty Kazakhstan where they died
with the authoritarian president
nursultan nazarbayev
mr. Clinton handed the kazakh president
a propaganda coup when he expressed
support from Nazarbayev's bid to head an
international elections monitoring group
undercutting American foreign policy and
criticism of Kazakhstan's pork human
rights record by among others his wife
who was then a senator within days of
the visit jester's fledgling company
Eurasia Energy signed a preliminary deal
giving its takes in three uranium mines
controlled by the state-run uranium
agency has that come from okay so now
you're Eurasia which is just rows
company owns a bunch of assets in
Kazakhstan this by the way is one of the
reasons the Russians wanted to buy the
company this this us-based company they
wanted to buy the company because they
didn't just want the holdings in the
United States they really want more one
of the holdings in Kazakhstan Eurasia
into this company in 2007 merged with
uranium one at that point that was when
just row says that he divested himself
but the new company was controlled by
Eurasia investors including the item
Indians Helfer a Canadian who became
chairman just for me about forty five
million bucks off the deal and and he
sold his stake but he had given a bunch
of money to the Clinton so that in
itself is is you know an element of
corruption although Hillary is not yet
Secretary of State uranium one is all
according to the New York Times right
not according to me uranium one began to
snap up companies with the assets in the
United States in April 2007 it bought
uranium mills in Utah it bought in
Wyoming it bought in Texas and then The
Times published an article showing the
two thousand five trips linked to the
the Kazakhstan mining zeal between the
Clintons and the and uranium one and
just draw gesture I had donated
thirty-one point three million dollars
to Clinton's foundation okay and it's
the Clintons were still involved after
just truck dropped out so the idea here
from Shep Smith and some people are left
is once gesture was gone what are you
whining about here is the answer mister
Telfer
right who's the new head of uranium one
gave undisclosed donations of somewhere
between 1.3 million and five point six
million dollars in contributions they
are reported from a constellation of
people with ties to uranium one or
Eurasia
without those assets the Russians would
have had no interest in the deal the
Kazakh assets there had no interest in
the deals it was
just that it wasn't just that apparently
early on in the Obama administration it
looked like uranium one was not going to
be able to get what they needed from
Kazakhstan and so they went to the
Clintons and said can you help and
whether Hillary had anything to do with
her or not the State Department
intervened amid this influx of uranium
one connected money Bill Clinton was
invited to speak in Moscow in June 2010
the same month rasa tahn struck its
steel from a majority stake in uranium
one it was his single highest fee it was
a half a million dollar fee for Bill
Clinton paid by Renaissance Capital a
Russian investment bank with ties to the
Kremlin okay so it is not at all clear
that Hillary had nothing to do with this
it is not at all clear that uranium 1
was completely clean you know I think
that the most the most stretched
allegation is the idea that uranium 1
was greenlit by Hillary Clinton
personally but the idea that they
intervened in 2009 2010 the State
Department intervened a little bit to
help lift Kazakh issues for uranium 1
that's not out of bounds it's weird that
the entire Obama administration would
sign off on all of this knowing that
uranium 1 donations were going to the
Clinton Foundation all of this is worthy
of investigation so that's the answer
number one yes this is worthy of
investigation no it's not quite as clear
cut as Shep Smith wanted to make it ok
question number two does this deserve a
special counsel so this is a different
question special counsel suggests that
the people who are in charge of
investigating namely jeff Sessions he's
not capable of doing a full
investigation remember those are people
that we hire right Jeff Sessions the guy
we already paid to do these
investigations the reason we have a
special counsel now is because of Donald
Trump ok Jeff Sessions originally
recused himself because he testified
wrongly that he had never met with
anybody from Russia this of course was
not true and so he recused himself in
the Russia investigation but the next
guy and the totem pole was not the
Special Counsel it was rod Rosenstein
the reason rod Rosenstein recused
himself an appointed a special counsel
is because Trump tried to use rod
Rosenstein as a rationale for firing
James Comey that forced Rosen scene to
appoint a special counsel so now you're
saying that on the hillary stuff
sessions isn't capable of investigating
I don't really see why now you sound the
hillary stuff that Rosenstein is
incapable of investigating i don't
really see why so I'm not sure why
special counsel is necessary as opposed
to a normal DOJ investigation so
sessions has just been batted about by
both sides in Congress the Democrats are
bashing sessions about by suggesting
he's dishonest then he lied about his
Russian ties I find that very hard to
believe
and then the people on the right are
bashing him about for not appointing a
special counsel as Donald Trump
easily wants to quote-unquote lock her
up my sympathies are largely with Jeff
sessions here so we'll start with Jeff
sessions talking to ted Lieu the the
egregiously ban California Congress
person he's he's currently running
against a guy that I have endorsed in in
his race and ted Lieu went after
sessions and said that he was basically
a liar about russia he recessions
response yesterday on the hill i won't
repeat it mr. chairman but I hope the
congressman knows and I hope all of you
know that my answer to that question I
did not meet with the Russians was
explicitly responding to the shocking
suggestion that I as a surrogate was
meeting on a continuing basis with
Russian officials and the implication
was to impact the campaign in some sort
of nefarious way and all I did was meet
in my office with the Ambassador which
we didn't discuss anything like that so
I just want to say I appreciate the
congressman's right I guess he can sighs
free speech he can't be sued here so
it's just my response so basically their
sessions saying you know if I could sue
you I would but there is a the a
parliamentary immunity so you can see
what everyone on the floor of Congress
sessions then was asked by trey Gowdy
and Jim and Jim Jordan from Ohio why he
was not setting up a Hillary special
counsel again I don't think sessions is
doing the wrong thing here I think that
just because the Eric Holder politicized
the Department of Justice and used it as
a political weapon on behalf of Barack
Obama just cuz he called himself Obama's
wing man and then went out and acted
like it doesn't mean that the goj can
afford to have every Attorney General be
used as a baton by the administration
and I think sessions is saying something
true here here he was asked why he's not
setting up a special counsel for Hillary
and here was his answer
well mr. Comey is no longer the director
the FBI thank goodness we have an
excellent man of integrity and ability
and Chris Ray and I think he's going to
do an outstanding job and I'm very happy
I would say tomorrow night asking for us
a time the gentleman I would say looks
like is not enough basis to appoint a
special counsel okay and that is the
proper legal standard Jeff Sessions is
just
his job he takes an enormous amount of
crap for it but sessions on this
particular issue while the Democrats are
ripping him for being unfair sessions is
the one who basically appointed the
special counsel you know to investigate
the 2016 election and it was sessions
who right now is saying listen I need a
legal standard in order for me to meet
that legal standard by the way it's not
like sessions isn't doing his job
I mean sessions said yesterday that they
are in full investigation mode against
27 separate leaks outside of the Trump
administration here's what he had to say
on that we had about none open
investigations of classified leaks in
the last three years we have twenty
seven investigations open today we
intend to get to the bottom of these
leaks I think it reached has reached
epidemic proportions it cannot be
allowed to continue and we will do our
best effort to ensure that it does not
continue you know this is one of the
things that people don't get about the
Trump administration you saw a bunch of
Democrats were going around saying Trump
should be impeached bob corker today we
should remove the ability for Trump to
launch a nuclear weapons outside of what
Trump says and the fact that no major
legislation has been passed when Trump
leaves his department heads alone what
they do is within not only within the
normal bounds of political conduct it is
typically quite good Jeff Sessions has
been fine as the Attorney General and
all the crap he's had to take in order
to do that is I think a foolish mistake
on the part of people on the right and
the left okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like this week I've been
encouraged by by Andrew Klavan and by
Michael Mills the execrable Michael
Mills sorry as I say I experiment
incredible to read this book poetic
diction by Owen Barfield it is a
supremely pretentious book but it does
have a lot of interesting things to say
about what it is that makes poetry reach
us and how human language has changed
over time and really how human
understanding of the world has changed
over time and has simultaneously
enriched our the the variety of language
while undercutting the innate richness
of each word so the sort of idea the
sort of thesis behind poetic diction is
that a long time ago when you look at
words like Ruach in the bible Ruach
means it means both wind and
and so we have two words for that right
we have wind and spirit when you read
old ancient books and you read the word
rueake it has a different sense right a
different a sense of richness to it then
neither wit nor spirit really does
justice to because it includes both the
reason for that says Barfield is because
people perceived more meaning to be
associated with the physical world than
they necessarily perceived to be
associated with the physical world today
and so we've been more specific with our
language but that also that's
specificity means that when we read the
word winds now it doesn't have the same
impact as when we read older poetry when
you read a homer it feels replete with a
certain meaning that modern poetry just
can't match and that's because the
language itself of the time was richer
in content if not in variety so that's
that sort of the basic ideas it's it's
an interesting book I think that it has
some really good insights about how
language is used and how the use of the
devolves over time okay time for some
things that I hate
all right so thing that I hate number
one so Joe Biden obviously wants to run
for president again I will be curious to
see if there's any widespread media
investigation of allegations that have
been made by former Secret Service
agents that he mistreated female Secret
Service agents those have been this has
been alleged in a couple of places that
I've seen all of these allegations I
believe should be should be hunted down
and researched to the fullest extent by
Biden obviously wants to run for
president again he's making the rounds
he think he would have one last time
there's a poll out today that shows that
Biden would beat Donald Trump if the
election were held today 46 to 34
something along those lines
in a in a sort of normal Democrat versus
Trump election it would be something
like 48 to 34 in any case Biden is
making the rounds and he was asked
specifically about the shooting in Texas
that recent church shooting in Texas and
he was asked why would you want to
remove the gun from the hands of the guy
who stopped the church shooter right
that this the the Stephen Willeford the
the NRA former a gun instructor hero who
shot the bad guy and here was Biden's
response which is truly insane well
first of all the kind of gun being
carried he shouldn't be carrying assault
weapons are I I wrote the first the last
serious gun control law that was written
it was law for 10 years and
long assault weapons and a lot long
weapons with magazines that had a whole
lot of bullets and so you can kill a
whole lot of people a lot more quickly
number one number two it's just rational
to say certain people shouldn't have
guns now the fact that some people with
guns are legally able to acquire a gun
and they turn out to be crazy after the
fact that's that's life there's nothing
you can do about that but we can save a
lot of lives and we've stopped tens of
thousands of people from getting guns
who shouldn't have guns well including
presumably the guy who shot the bad guy
so the Joe Biden knows less about guns
than virtually anyone else I mean
there's a guy who said that you should
shoot through the front door of your
house if so with the shotgun or I should
go out on your balcony and you should
you should blow a couple rounds and it's
just he's ridiculous but you wonder why
people think that the Democrats are gun
grabbers it's because of this here's the
question that probably though that
preceded this answer was specifically
about whether the shooter of the bad guy
should have had a gun and that was Biden
specific answer pretty amazing okay
other things that I hate so Shannon
Sharpe who has become a frequent
contributor to things I hate so I
appreciate his presence on Fox Sports 1
he says he's praising Colin Kaepernick
so Colin Kaepernick was named the GQ
Person of the Year citizen of the year
which makes perfect sense since he
didn't vote he doesn't speak publicly
and he doesn't have much to say any more
socks that had cops depicted his pigs
obviously that is the Citizen of the
year but Shannon Sharpe says the
Kaepernick will go down in history as a
mythical civil rights figure maybe Colin
Kaepernick will never get the respect
that he deserves for what he did but I
believe when it's all said and done in
history is written 30 40 years from now
Colin Kaepernick will be looked upon as
some of these mythical figures of the
dr. King's the Muhammad Ali's and the
Rose apart okay first of all to compare
Colin Kaepernick to Martin Luther King
is utterly objectin sane Martin Luther
King not only provided a message that
inspired millions of people it was a
uniting message to compare him to Rosa
Parks is also insane Rosa Parks helped
organize with the n-double a-c-p the
legal pretext for ending legalized
segregation in the United States nothing
like that is a current it's compared to
Muhammad Ali however is a little bit
different come
him to Muhammad Ali actually is is not
too far off because if you go back and
look at what Muhammad Ali was saying
during the 60s in the early 70s a lot of
it was quite extreme a lot of those
quite anti-american there's been a
rewriting of Muhammad Ali's histories
how's it possible that 30 years from now
the left will have rewritten colin
kaepernick into some sort of gentleman
hero it's certainly a possibility but
now just demonstrate that history can be
rewritten in a myriad of false ways okay
so I was gonna do some Bible talk this
week but actually did some Bible talk
last some extra Bible talk in in last
week's mailbag so if you want Bible talk
go back and listen to that but we have
to break so that I can get on a plane
and come back home and do my show from
the studio tomorrow thanks again to the
folks over at fox news for allowing me
to use the studio I really appreciate it
and we will see you tomorrow I'm entropy
row this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]